i've worked at hillsdale college
for
a little over 20 years now which is
hard to believe but it's been a lot of
fun
to watch the college grow and extend its
reach
nationwide
guided all the all the while by
the college's original 1844 founding
mission
as our trustee chris batchelder
mentioned on campus the quality of the
faculty
and the students is better than ever
and off campus more americans learn from
hillsdale college
than ever before
just think of the more than 5.6 million
readers of in primus
where the more than 2.5 million
americans who have signed up and taken
one of our one or more of our online
courses
well we go about our work every day at
hillsdale under the direction and
leadership of our next speaker
he's been the pilot of the hillsdale
college ship
for almost 21 years this year
he's a scholar of winston churchill
he's a prolific and best-selling author
he's a professor of history and politics
including a recent course on
totalitarian novels
you may not know that he's also a big
fan of baseball and tennis
and he's an avid motorcyclist
in recent years he's he's led a
two-wheeled gang
on a big summer road trip
i don't know where they're going this
year
but he may tell us would you please
welcome to the podium the 12th president
of hillsdale college larry pjarne
[Applause]
thank you tim
this year we're going to the ozarks
because i'm from arkansas and i want to
see all my cousins
if you think
2020 was bad wait till it turns 21 and
starts drinking
kathy gramer where's kathy hold up your
hand kathy
yeah she's ordered me to give you reason
for optimism
so i'm going to say a bunch of bad stuff
there are things to worry about
um
we're suffering from a mental pandemic
and that has caused them to interfere
with the rights
of
millions of americans
destroyed their businesses
our governor
in michigan
a brilliant states woman she is too
she spends her days
you know she's got more than a thousand
pages of rules
and
they're contradictory and stupid
and and the first thing is if you know
how to run anything you know
rules are always a bad idea
you know when i came to hillsdale
college we had 134 pages of student
rules
now we have 17 rules not pages of rules
rules
right and that means we can kind of know
what they are although 17 is too many to
carry in your
mind
the one great rule is
behave yourself
be good
they swear and always in an honor code
to do that right
and that's really the only rule you need
but she's like that right and
she has uh messed with our college
right now the score is hillsdale three
governor zero
[Music]
[Applause]
but it's irksome because
you know somebody there's some supposed
right wingers that disappeared when they
found out they were antifa people
tr
had a plot to kidnap her
and so i was asked by a journalist
would you know anybody who'd want to do
that and i said i don't know anybody
who'd even like to meet her
[Applause]
see that's optimism kathy
that's a tragic thing i'm describing but
it's funny
you know
the election was a massive corruption
and disorder
[Music]
tomorrow i'm going to tell you about
some state legislators in an unnamed
state that might be one that i would
know a lot about
whatever state that was
and
it will make you sad
also show us what to do
and now the government is in the hands
of
radical liberalism
oh i got to have my prop
grace bring me that book over there
this is the great grace balkan
[Applause]
oh yeah also that the the prayer girl
taryn murphy
outstanding senior woman and she is
dating the useless grant wood
who's about to go into the marine corps
and i think now that she's reached her
glory
she'll see better than that
[Laughter]
actually grant is a very fine young man
just unworthy of karen
so on the first day of the biden
administration we were up first
he canceled the 1776
commission
and
erased the report from the white house
they were mad at it because uh
we had five weeks to form a commission
have meetings write a report
agree to it unanimously
and then pub design publish it and get
it out
and we were destroyed because the
government doesn't like things to move
like that
but now it's been completely obliterated
except wait
it's uh
just been published by encounter books
and we've added footnotes
uh and the footnotes are two two things
they're two original source documents
and they are two leading historians some
of whom have attacked us
who say exactly the same thing in their
own books
so that'll be fun and it's a little book
you should get it
write me and i'll send it to you also
joe biden is the honorary chair of our
marketing campaign
at last
somewhere where he's effective
the worst thing of all is uh
they're messing with the electoral
system
and i'll talk about that some tomorrow
but the truth is in a representative
form of government
the linchpin of it the crucial point
is the voting system
and so
you know i believe that in the obama
years they figured out that un
uh
unexpectedly
people don't actually like what they do
and so they might have reformed and
moderated themselves
but instead what they did was they
decided we're going to make them
and i think we're living under that
effort right now
so that's the bad stuff how am i doing
kathy
but i know three pieces of delightful
news
powerful news
a two i'm going to tell you right now
and the other one tomorrow
the first one is
hillsdale college is just thriving it's
just marvelous to us
[Applause]
and we're stubborn cusses and we're not
given to counting our successes because
when we're dead we can do that
but
it's you know it's been successful for a
long time
now it's more it's just amazing like
our entering class next year
is going to have an entering
standardized test score one percent one
point
below the
ivy league
so it's about 25th in the country
and
and we could fill up another college at
those standards now
and
everything is like that you've been very
generous with us thank you very much
uh our students are now paying about
seven percent of the budget of hillsdale
college
and that means we don't need them and we
can tell them so
and that's really good for them
because you know there's they'll be
spoiled babies if we don't torture them
do you know how
do you know how many people getting
primus
almost six million
isn't that crazy and
do you know how many people have
registered for online courses in
hillsdale college in the last what is it
eight or nine years
almost three million
and
growing faster now
than previously
and what are those courses right
the latest one is euclid
uh
it's already got 10 000 people taking it
aristotle
dante is coming soon right what isn't
that amazing phenomenon
i get recognized in airports now
and
and people walk up to me and they talk
to me like they're students you know
just like just like on the campus
oh your doctor and i said yes indeed and
he says well you know we just love your
course
and i say
are you taking the exams
[Music]
and they do exactly what students do
they look at their feet and kind of
shuffle around
[Laughter]
they're afraid i'm going to look up
their score
that's all
good news and i submit to you kathy
cramer
world changing news
just remember
all the best things
every great thing ever done in human
history
is done by a volunteer and somebody who
does it for love
[Applause]
the second great news tonight is our
speaker tonight
uh somewhere near the center of our
problems
i'll talk about this a little tomorrow
too because i learned it from once the
churchill
is the corruption of the ancient and
natural way of knowing
called natural science
it's a beautiful thing we know more
about the material and natural world
than we ever have
but the weight of those disciplines has
turned not from science to from science
which just means knowing in latin
to technology which means making
and making is not the same thing as
knowing
making is an exercise in power
so it's no accident that
we are governed by
supposedly scientists
i mean i i can i can talk all day about
the governor of michigan
i still managed you know if she was
beating me i would
it'd be heart-rending to me but so far
we're doing pretty good so
i can talk about her
she was asked
there are what 40 or 50 000
uh scott atlas will know
medical researchers and some of the many
of the leading epidemiologists of the
world who have signed the great
barrington declaration which says
this is all crazy
you know facebook took it down the other
day
i had an argument with a medical doctor
a friend a good guy
at the mayo clinic and he said well
you're using the epidemiologists that
are for opening up and i said correct
and he said you knew that already and i
said yeah what do you think i'm running
a scientific experiment here
i'm running to college
i it's my duty to have college it's my
duty to find a way that's safe because
if as i tell the students all the time
if you get sick and die from this it's
going to be very inconvenient to me
which you know it's true and i have a
stake in protecting them right
but on the other hand my job is to have
college
and so
this doctor who's got kids at hillsdale
college and came to our commencement i
said you've just proved my point
and he said how and i said
you guys are the best in the world at
the mayo clinic aren't you
he said we're pretty good and i said how
about these guys at stanford
are they pretty good
and he says yeah and i said see
you don't agree
experts never do
about a practical judgment they will by
the way eventually reach an agreement
about the facts that can be measured if
they're any use at all
but this thing about what to do about
this pandemic when you have the power to
shut down the largest economy in the
history of the world
that's a thing of massive and
incalculable consequences
and nobody can be an expert in that
and he said well you got a good point
and i said thank you very much
and
and
on the other hand i did need to know
if i was going to kill these kids
because they say it just caused me a
world of trouble if i did
where'd i learn it
three people one of them our speaker
tonight
three top people
and three people who it turns out
are brave
because they stood up against this
uh their names are the ones who helped
us are uh
jay bhattacharya from stanford
and daniel
halperin from north carolina
and then the toughest of them all
scott atlas our speaker tonight
and
you know a great intellectual argument
is always some wisdom of intellectual
and moral power
because you have to be brave to speak
the truth in the face of consequences
scott atlas is one of the leading
physicians in the world
he wrote the book on
magnetic rem resonance imaging of the
brain and the spine
and somehow
in the course of writing on that he
delivered he developed both
and his is strong
uh he did work for the president for
president trump for a while
and
the point is
it's it's such a
violent culture today
that for a leading scientist to offer
his counsel to the president of the
united states
when there are people dying as there are
and that is a disgrace
that tells you where the country is
i say he's a
a
cause for optimism
because
i didn't know him before this came up
and so that means that i and all of us
every one of us
has discovered a brave and brilliant man
and the only correct conclusion to draw
draw from that is
there must be more
and we are stronger by knowing him
please come up here scott
as you know hillsdale college is very
old
not long in the tooth
and
this award that i'm about to give scott
we've been given here for more than 40
years
and we've given it to ronald reagan and
we've given to margaret thatcher and
we've given it to clarence thomas
and you know some other
small names
and it's called the freedom leadership
award
and that means
leadership which takes courage
toward freedom which is a generosity
everyone it touches
i'm proud to present this award to scott
atlas
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much
thank you president darn supporters of
hillsdale and hillsdale's national
leadership seminar program and members
of this distinguished audience
it's a great honor to be here
it's my first exposure
to hillsdale
and it's awesome i am really thrilled to
be here
[Applause]
i'm very very grateful to receive the
award i'm of course highly honored to be
on the list of winners
and i sincerely thank everyone who had
anything to do with this
it's also great to be in a crowd that is
friendly for a change
[Applause]
hillsdale's national leadership seminar
program as everyone here knows was
founded with a specific mission quote to
foster enlightened leadership and
informed decision-making for america's
third century by communicating the
fundamental principles of freedom and
order
on which western civilization is based
unquote
the pandemic has been a tragedy no doubt
but it has exposed profound issues in
america that now threaten those very
principles of freedom and order that we
americans too often take for granted
first
i must say i was shocked at the enormous
power of the government to unilaterally
decree to simply close businesses and
schools restrict personal movement
mandate behavior eliminate our most
basic freedoms without any end
and second
i was and i remain stunned
and a little bit frightened
at the acquiescence of the american
people to these destructive arbitrary
and wholly unscientific rules
restrictions and mandates
[Applause]
this crisis also exposed what we have
all known existed but we tolerated
although i think hillsdale didn't
tolerate it as much as everyone else
but the rest of the country
tolerated for years the bias of the
media the suppression of academic
freedom on campuses the lack of
neutrality in big tech and now more
obviously than ever
the politicization of science
ultimately the freedom to seek and state
the truth is at risk here in the united
states
first we all acknowledge the
consequences of the sars2 coronavirus
pandemic and its management have been
enormous
over five hundred thousand american
deaths have been attributed to the virus
more will certainly follow
even after a year the pandemic still
paralyzes our country and despite all
efforts there has been an undeniable
failure to stop the cases from rapidly
escalating and preventing
hospitalizations and death
but here's the unacknowledged reality
almost every state and major city
has implemented severe restrictions for
many months including closures of
businesses and in-person schools
mobility restrictions curfews
quarantines limits on groups and
families and mass mandates dating back
to at least the summer
and let's clear up the myths about the
behavior of americans social mobility
tracking and data from gallup yougov the
covet 19 consortium and the cdc have
shown significant reductions of movement
as well as consistently high percentage
of mask wearing since late last summer
similar to western europe and
approaching that in asia there is no
truth to the fact that these mandates
were not obeyed
all legitimate policy scholars
today
should be re-examining policies that
severely harmed americans families and
children and failed to save the elderly
numerous studies including one from my
current institution stanford
university's infectious disease
scientists and epidemiologists ben david
o bhattacharya and ian nedes have shown
the mitigating impact of these
extraordinary measures used in almost
every state was small at best president
biden openly admitted this lack of
efficacy in his speech on january 22nd
when he said quote there is nothing we
can do to change the trajectory of the
pandemic in the next several months
unquote
bizarrely though
many want to blame those who oppose the
lockdowns and then mandates for the
failure of the lockdowns and the
mandates that were widely implemented
separate from their limited value
efficacy that has been grossly
exaggerated in scientific journals
lockdown policies have been
extraordinarily harmful
the harms to children of closing in
person schools are dramatic poor
learning school dropout social isolation
suicidal ideation
most of which are far worse for lower
income families
a recent study confirms up to 78 of
cancers were never detected due to miss
screening over three months and
extrapolating to the entire country
over a million new cases over nine
months of cancer will have gone
undetected
that disaster adds to missed surgeries
delayed presentations of pediatric
illnesses heart attack and stroke
patients too afraid to call emergency
services and others all well documented
beyond hospital care the cdc reported
fourfold increases in depression
tripling of anxiety symptoms doubling of
suicidal ideation particularly among
young adults
after the first few months of lockdowns
domestic abuse child abuse skyrocketing
due to the isolation and specifically to
the loss of jobs
particularly in strict lockdown
states given that many in-person schools
have closed hundreds of thousands of
child abuse cases are not reported
because schools are where child abuse is
most frequently noted
finally the unemployment shock from the
lockdowns according to a recent nber
study
will generate
almost 890 000 additional us deaths
mainly in minority and poor families
over the next 15 years that's the
lockdown alone
we know we have not seen the full extent
of the damage because it will last for
decades perhaps that is why lockdowns
were never recommended in previous
pandemic analyses even for infections
with far higher death rates
to determine the best path forward
shouldn't policymakers now objectively
consider both the virus harms and the
totality of impact of the policies to
date
that's the importance of health policy
experts my field we have a broader scope
of expertise than that of
epidemiologists and basic scientists who
you see on tv every day
and that necessarily means admitting
that social lockdowns and significant
restrictions on individuals are deadly
extraordinarily harmful especially on
the working class minorities and the
poor
optimistically we should be seeing the
light at the end of the long tunnel now
with the vaccine rollout
on the other hand
using logic that would put alice in
wonderland's mad hatter to shame
the new vaccines were first more
frequently administered to healthier
younger people instead of those at risk
to die in most states
and now we hear children must be
vaccinated before schools open when they
have extremely low risk from this
infection and are proven to not be
significant spreaders to adults
or the kafka asked nonsense that
teachers must be vaccinated before they
teach in person when schools are the one
of the lowest risk environments and the
vast majority of teachers are not high
risk
even worse we hear the same old
so-called experts on tv
now warning that social distancing masks
and other restrictions will still be
necessary after vaccines
there is no intention of those in power
to allow americans to live normally to
live freely again and don't ever think
otherwise
[Applause]
just as in galileo's time the real
problem is what he called quote vested
academic interests unquote
many universities
which should be america's centers for
critical thinking
have overtly intimidated views contrary
to their own
undoubtedly undeniably out of political
reasons leaving many afraid to speak up
i know i get their emails for months
people encouraging me but are afraid to
step forward
but it is not only the matter of
academic freedom that needs comment
instead of rethinking the failed
policies
some stanford professors have chosen to
employ toxic smears and opinion pieces
and organize rebukes against those of us
who disagreed with what was implemented
but worse who dared to help the country
under a president they despised
apparently the ultimate transgression
defamatory attacks with malicious intent
based on straw man arguments and
out-of-context distortions
are not acceptable in civilized society
let alone in our universities
in their attempt to intimidate and
discredit me using falsifications and
misrepresentations
a group of untruthful professors
violated with impunity stanford's code
of conduct damaged the stanford name and
most importantly abuse the trust parents
and society place in them to influence
america's children our next generation
of leaders
this is unacceptable
it is understandable that most stanford
professors are not experts in my field
health policy
and even that most are ignorant of the
data about the pandemic but it is not
acceptable to claim i made
recommendations that were quote
falsehoods and misrepresentations of
science that is a lie
and no matter how often a lie is
repeated and regardless of how often
those lies are echoed in the media lies
do not transform into truths
we all must pray to god that the phrase
attributed to nazi propagandist joseph
goebbels quote a lie told once remains a
lie but a lie told a thousand times
becomes the truth unto un unquote
never becomes true in these united
states of america
[Applause]
all policy considerations i recommended
to the president were designed to reduce
both the spread of the virus to the most
vulnerable and the harms to those
impacted by the policies the most the
poor and working class of america
i was one of the first to push for
increasing protections to those most at
risk particularly the elderly almost a
year ago i recognized we must consider
the enormous harms to physical health
mental health in lives lost coming
directly from the draconian policies
that attempted to contain the infection
that is the most appropriate goal of
people in public health policy to
minimize all harms not simply to stop
covert 19 at all costs
the claim in a recent journal of the ama
opinion piece a vicious piece written by
three stanford professors
that said quote nearly all public health
experts were concerned that atlas's
recommendations could lead to tens of
thousands of unnecessary deaths in the
united states alone unquote
is patently false absurd on its face
as professor arn mentioned the proposal
called the great barrington declaration
co-authored by some of the world's best
medical scientists and epidemiologists
from stanford harvard and oxford is
quote far closer to the one condemned in
the jama article than anything atlas
said unquote as pointed out by zinberg
yet that policy document has already
been signed by over 50 000 medical and
public health practitioners
when critics display such ignorance
about the scope of views held by experts
it exposes their overt bias and wholly
disqualifies their authority on these
issues indeed it is almost beyond parity
that these same stanford critics wrote
quote professionalism demands honesty
about what they know and do not know
unquote
it is true that i have explained the
fact that younger people have little
risk from this infection as well as the
biological concept of herd immunity the
most radioactive term in the pandemic
discussion
that explanation is very different from
proposing that people be deliberately
exposed and infected i have never done
that to the contrary i have repeatedly
called for mitigation measures including
extra sanitization social distancing
masks when appropriate group limits
testing and other increased protections
to limit the spread and the damage from
the virus i explicitly call for
augmenting protection of those at risk
in dozens of on the record presentations
interviews and written pieces
yet one must question why these accusers
ignore these explicit emphatic
denials of me beyond those presentations
that i ever supported spreading the
infection unchecked to achieve herd
immunity these denials were quoted
widely in the media are not my own
statements the object of their criticism
in the first place or might it be
something else might it be due to these
stanford professors own political rage
their own desire to delegitimize anyone
who had the audacity to help the country
under president trump
for many months i was vilified after
calling for opening in-person schools
the same exact policy that harvard
professors martin calder from catherine
e and stanford professor and my good
friend jay bhattacharya called for
but this policy has been corroborated
upheld with all the evidence repeatedly
for months the compelling case to open
schools is admitted to be long-standing
truth now even in lay publications like
the atlantic
they said quote research from around the
world has since the beginning of the
pandemic
indicated that people under 18 and
especially younger kids are less
susceptible to infection less likely to
experience severe symptoms and far less
likely to be hospitalized or die unquote
and quote we've known for months that
young children are less susceptible to
serious infection and less likely to
transmit the virus let's act like it
unquote
the jama accusers further stated atlas
disputed the need for mass unquote
talk about radioactive issues let's talk
about masks
to the contrary my advice on mask usage
was consistent and i said it more than a
hundred times
wear a mask when you cannot socially
distance quote unquote
what's funny is that that matches almost
verbatim the published recommendations
of the world health organization quote
when outside wear a mask if you cannot
maintain physical distance from others
unquote
and in december they changed it to quote
in areas where the virus is circulating
mass should be worn when you're in
crowded settings when you can't be one
meter
from others and in rooms with poor or
unknown ventilation unquote i.e
not at all times by everyone that also
matches the nih
quote when consistent distancing is not
possible face coverings may further
reduce the spread of infectious droplets
from individuals with sars2 covered
infection to others unquote you'll never
hear that on cnn
you may not watch cnn
[Applause]
let's talk about universal mass usage in
the general population
38 states have implemented mass mandates
most since at least the summer with
almost all the rest having major city
mask mandates
widespread general population mask usage
has shown little empirical utility for
stopping cases all over the world every
state in the country even though
describing that evidence has been
censored
widespread mass usage shows only minimal
impact in the one large randomized
controlled study from denmark here's the
reality those who insist that universal
mass usage is absolutely proven
effective at controlling the spread of
this virus and somehow is universally
recommended by the science
are deliberately ignoring the evidence
of the contrary and they are propagating
false and misleading information
[Applause]
those who charge that it is unethical or
dangerous to question broad population
mass mandates must explain why several
of the world's top infectious disease
scientists and public health
organizations overtly question the
efficacy of general population mask
jefferson and hennigan of oxford center
for evidence-based medicine wrote quote
it would appear that despite two decades
of pandemic preparedness there is
considerable uncertainty as the value of
wearing masks unquote oxford sinetra
gupta said there is no need for mass
unless one is elderly or high risk
stanford's jay bhattacharya stated quote
mass mandates are not supported by the
scientific data there is no scientific
evidence that mask mandates work to slow
the spread of the disease unquote
throughout the pandemic the who said at
present there is no direct evidence on
the effectiveness of universal masking
of healthy people in the community to
prevent infection with respiratory
viruses including covet 19 unquote the
cdc reviewed influenza pandemics and
published in may
quote they did not find evidence that
surgical type face masks are effective
in reducing laboratory confirmed
influenza transmission either when worn
by infected persons source control or by
persons in the general community to
reduce their susceptibility unquote
and until the who removed the quote that
i used
of theirs in my tweet that was withdrawn
and censored by twitter they had posted
until the very next day
quote at the present time the widespread
use of mass by healthy people in the
community setting is not yet supported
by high quality or direct scientific
evidence and there are potential
benefits and harms to consider
period
at this point
one could make a strong case that those
who continue to push societal
restrictions without acknowledging their
failures and serious harms are
themselves putting forth dangerous
misinformation
but i will not call for their official
rebuke or punishment i will not try to
cancel them i will not try to extinguish
their opinions and i will not lie to
distort their words and defame them
to do so would repeat their shameful
behavior of intimidating discourse that
is critical to educating the public and
arriving at the scientific truths we
desperately need
it's time to consider
that university models like harvard's
truth stanford's the winds of freedom
blow and yale's light and truth need
major revision
social media has piled on with a heavy
hand now to eliminate discussion of
conflicting evidence
without permitting without indeed
encouraging open debate
and admission of errors we might never
solve any future crisis
as a health policy scholar
for over 15 years and as a professor at
top universities for 30 years i am
shocked at what i see
some faculty members of our acclaimed
universities are now dangerously
intolerant dangerously intolerant
of opinions that they don't agree with
[Applause]
some go even further
distorting and misrepresenting words to
delegitimize and even calling for
punishment of those of us willing to
serve the country alongside a polarizing
president that they happen to loathe
it is their behavior to quote those same
professors rebuking me that quote
violates the core values of stanford
faculty and the expectations under the
stanford code of conduct which states
quote we are all responsible for
sustaining the high ethical standards of
this institution unquote
but worse than that violation of ethical
behavior among colleagues their behavior
does not meet the standard of simple
human decency
if academic leaders if the entire
academic community
fails to stand up and renounce that
unethical conduct many more experts with
a reputation to lose will be unwilling
to serve their country in contentious
times
as educators as parents as fellow
citizens that would be the worst
possible legacy to leave to our children
i also fear that the concept the science
has been seriously damaged
[Applause]
even the best journals in the world new
england journal of medicine lancet
science nature and journal of the ama
have become overtly contaminated by
politics
many unfortunately have now become
fatigued by these arguments
that is even worse
because if the public becomes fatigued
that will allow fallacy to triumph over
truth
[Applause]
if the social media continues to be the
arbiter of allowable discussion
the united states is on the precipice of
losing its cherished freedoms
with censorship and cancellation of all
those who bring views forward that
differ from the accepted mainstream
i stand here
honestly more renewed than i was when i
walked in this building because i have
never seen hillsdale college before
i will say this in conclusion
while it is not clear if our democracy
will survive it is obvious that people
must step up and i may say rise up or it
has no chance thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you dr ellis we now have time for
some q a if you have a question please
raise your hand and wait for a
microphone to be brought to you
sir
um
i am
75 years old and sort of on the horns of
a dilemma and that dilemma is
whether or not to get the vaccination so
what's your opinion of what we should do
under these circumstances
okay this is a common question actually
tonight uh before the dinner
um so i mean i'll first say i'm not
anybody's doctor here and you should
consult with your doctor
i can say this and this is what i i tell
people i think and i've said it on the
podium in the press briefing room so i i
feel that people
who are at risk
should get the vaccine
and what i mean by that is besides the
people who have high risk conditions
people who are generally over roughly 65
it's advisable to get the vaccine
and i say that for two reasons
one is that the risk of the vaccine
is smaller than the risk from covet 19
for people who are old
i consider myself
i don't consider myself old but i did
get the vaccine two days ago
and the second reason is sort of a
secondary reason but it's the reality of
the country we're living in the world
we're living in
i believe
i don't want it to be true but i believe
that we're probably going to be required
to show that we had the vaccine before
we're allowed to do certain things i
actually believe that it's sad
but this is the world we're looking at
and what i'm talking about specifically
is things like international travel i
believe i have no inside knowledge on
this i'm not in the discussion at all
that countries
could easily start requiring that and i
do travel quite a bit uh
so
those two things in the right age group
i think it's advisable to get the
vaccine and i think it probably will be
required although i have no inside
knowledge on that
if you're asking me should everyone get
the vaccine
again i'm going to say it's a personal
decision
with you and your doctor
i do not believe for one second that
people should be required to get a
vaccine no i am completely opposed to
that
[Applause]
if you're low risk and young
i think there's a strong case to not
take the vaccine
i have two children of my own in that
age group and i've advised them
accordingly but again like it's a
personal decision
uh you know there are certain risks i
would say this if i can go on a little
bit uh
i was there
from what i saw and what i know there
were no corners cut on the vaccine
development
in fact there were extra delays put in
against standards
to delay the emergency use authorization
so i do not believe at all
that the vaccines were somehow
short-circuiting safety measures
i disagree with that
there is a certain percentage of
complications from any time you're going
to inject into your body something
that's clear and the vaccines are in
that category
but it's a it's a cost benefit or a risk
been a a risk sort of benefit assessment
for an individual
we have a question on the speaker's left
dr atlas i just recently read and i
can't say who quoted it but it was a
quote that's saying that those who had
the coronavirus and then who recovered
should only get the first shot
of the
of the
inoculation and i thought
presumably if you've had the disease you
have the antibodies you have the memory
cells in your blood what the heck is
that about that they should get the
first shot do you have an opinion on
that have you heard that i can't
remember who said it yes
so i mean there's two parts to that
really that are important one is
when you're talking about prioritizing
vaccines this is one of the things that
is again like
this is i i've said on tv i feel like
i'm living in a kafka novel here i mean
there's never been anyone that says
in the administration or in the people
that are in charge nowadays that says
that you should not be a priority if you
had the infection
and of course you should not be a
priority i'm not saying you should never
take the vaccine but you don't you don't
need it right away
you should immunize the people
who have a high risk to die and if
you've had the infection you have
biological protection that's just that's
fact that's high school ap biology
that's not even medical school
and that's what the research shows but
somehow that's just not discussed
the second part of your question is
there is a
there is
some evidence
that people that have had the infection
when they get the first dose they have
the same immune response to the first
dose
quantitatively as a
regular person without the infection who
had both doses that's where that's
coming from so if you have the ex
immune response
after two doses and you've never had the
infection if you take somebody who's had
the infection gets the first dose they
also have ax immune response so they are
sort of fully protected or equivalently
protected that's where that comes from i
don't have an opinion
on how that will be but i do have an
opinion that people who have had the
infection should not be the first
priority to get vaccinated we should
vaccinate the people who are at high
risk to die that's the only reason to do
vaccines is to stop people from dying
hello hi um i want to first congratulate
you it was a wonderful speech and it had
a lot to say
thank you very much
secondly is this going to be available
to us in a written form that we're
allowed to ask for
uh i think it's going to be it's on the
internet if i'm not mistaken
number one number two uh much of this
i'm going to submit
as a written piece
to one of the uh to the stand one of the
stanford newspapers
because
i'm i'm really tired of what's going on
and i'm not gonna take it i'm not gonna
take
[Applause]
uh dr atlas
i'll be 85 in may and i've been
inoculated so i'm ready to go but
all summer long
i turned on the tv
and i saw dr fauci and dr scarf
telling us what the science was in the
moment and i was wondering
if you could elaborate a little bit as
to how much of that was science
how much of that was
politics
uh well
no i have no hesitancy in telling the
truth i'll tell you it this way first i
wasn't there you have to remember i
didn't come in
until mid-august
so a lot of stuff was said
and then nothing was set because then
the president discontinued these press
conferences
um
what i saw
inside the white house
inside the what's called the situation
room where the task force meets
is incredible
it's shocking
it's outrageous
what was said
and
i'm going to have to write about that
one because it's amazing
but it's sort of frightening the level
of knowledge
the lack of knowledge of the current
data
and
i think the answer really can be summed
up is this these are people who are
government bureaucrats
these are people who have worked in
government jobs for 30 40 years
these are not
people who are challenged intellectually
by other people who come in and say well
what about this people like me and they
bring in a dozen scientific papers and
go through the data that didn't happen
before i got there
and uh
when you have people
who are
talking like they're talking now on tv
about well we should pass this bill or
something like this
that's not science
that's politics
so um
you know i think uh
it's tough to say the truth
it's actually easy to say the truth it's
it's tough to uh to watch people lie
about what you said
but a lot of things
that were said
were
sort of difficult to difficult to
believe i will say i'll i'll leave it at
that
to the man who asked if you're going to
get to read this the answer is yes
okay
we have a question on the speakers what
oh i apologize
thank you very much for your remarks
tonight they were tremendous and more so
thank you for your action and serving
our country
my question you referred to
the incredible power asserted by our
government to shut down the largest
economy
known in the history of mankind
without having set a goal or a purpose
i recall early on that there
was a goal of flattening the curve
and not necessarily
completely destroying the virus for all
time but
trying to
get the infection rate to be below the
capacities for emergency rooms etc
whatever happened to that and what is
the goal
i find myself asking that frequently
uh you're right and i remember it back
in the spring or whenever that was uh
the press conference that was a very
good press conference when dr burks
explained that we're going to flatten
the curve which only meant one thing
the hospitalizations
they didn't want to have
exceed capacity it had nothing to do
with stopping people from dying
if people want to talk mathematically
the area under the curve was never
changing
it was simply that they were going to
delay it so that a hospitals could could
treat people including by the way people
without covet which they failed to do
but that was voluntary and fear induced
but the second reason for the delay was
at least there was some uh
you know time for mobilizing resources
ramping up production of personal
protective equipment
getting a head start on drug development
these are all rational reasons to
temporarily
you know
close things and and uh
you may or may not remember but
president trump very early on and
repeatedly
said we cannot have the cure be worse
than the disease
and
there is something so obvious and yet so
wise about that it's obvious but nobody
else was saying it
and that is what happened so you're
right there has now been a complete
transformation of the goal to stopping
all cases of covet 19
and
it's completely irrational
it has proven to be impossible
and it is so destructive and harmful
uh that it is one of the most egregious
failures of health care policy really in
the history of the modern world i don't
know how to say it otherwise
we have a question on the speaker's left
hello can i ask you a question did you
know that the
arizona state legislature is in the
process of deciding whether people have
to wear masks
totally or
they can get away with not wearing a
mask and all they have to do is get in
touch with our state representative and
senators and
i would you can contact west valley
republican office thank you
no i didn't know
yes
thank you good evening thank you for
being here a two-part question the first
is
expressing a conundrum that i myself and
i think probably most of the people in
this room feel is a strong desire to
rise up
we feel powerless to make a difference
in a world that is forcing compliance if
you want to shop at home goods if you
want to go to home depot if you wanted
to go to the grocery store if you want
to live your life you must mask up
if you want to fly if you want to eat
while you're flying it's up and down
with the mask
what is your advice for those of us
who choose to believe the science as you
have described it to rise up in a way
that is impactful and can change
the way and the course that we are
facing the second part unrelated is
around the power of local public health
officials to determine
local public policy and health policy
that drive
the um the local policies that are
really impacting how we're living our
lives
thank you
okay so the rise up quote by the way
means make your voices heard
i know that you know a lot of people
went insane when i said that on twitter
rise up means stand up make your voices
heard that's what a democracy is all
about and so what i mean by
how you would do that
is exactly that you must be aggressively
contacting meaning be vocal contact your
representatives your local
representatives
you have to basically you we have to
make sure that the people in charge are
accountable to the people who are
in the population and they're not
accountable if we just sit there
and so uh you know i speak to i have
spoken many times with san diego
business community as one example
and you know these guys these people
they want to open their businesses and
so they have their city council members
sit in on these meetings they have their
it's all about
we are the people in charge in theory
and so we have to really we have to show
it it doesn't mean do something
destructive or violent or anything like
that that should be obvious to any
fair-minded person what we're saying
here but that means
be on the record say what you want i
mean the people of california are rising
up there's a recall vote going on with
the governor
[Applause]
now the second part of your question
about you know there's no simple answer
to the question there's no magic wand
here but it means
you know actually try to be impactful in
your local you know communities and and
get together as groups because i was
saying earlier the the individual person
who owns the gym who wants to stand up
to just open
okay that person is squashed and that
just it doesn't work
but it works if everybody opens
it works if all the restaurants say you
know what we're open
it works if the businesses say listen
you know we're we think we can open
if you don't want to go to a restaurant
don't go as a customer that's what i say
if you don't want to go to a gym don't
go
now the second part is these local
public health officials which is really
incredible this is again a something
that we never knew we never understood
who had this kind of power before i live
in santa clara county which is
probably the most restricted county in
the state of california
and uh you know this is a this is a
it's it's out of control it's insane
their numbers they're putting up make no
sense that's beyond arbitrary what
they're saying are these guidelines and
measures to open
and so the answer is and this is
beginning there is now scrutiny as to
who these people are and who are in
these positions because they never had
any impact before they were really
non-entities in a sense at least not not
impactful in our daily lives
they have created by their actions
spotlight on themselves and that that is
the answer is that we need to make sure
that we are on top of these people these
people are officials they're not in
charge unless we let them be in charge
so you know this is sort of a gradual
process it's an education for all of us
no one knew about these people i don't
think any of us had ever had you know
interacted with these people before so
uh we need to make sure
that we are holding these officials
accountable even at the local level not
just the state level the local level
they have tremendous control of your
lives
[Applause]
we have time for one more question
yes dr alice thank you for being here
it's a pleasure to hear your expertise
this evening i'm i'm just wondering as
as one who is choosing not to get the
vaccine could you possibly give your
opinion or speak to the effectiveness of
hydroxychloroquine or ivermectin
as treatment okay we're going to hit all
these hot topics
um
yeah i mean okay so there's a lot of
controversy about all these drugs the
the i'll give you a little bit of my
view of what happened with hydroxyl
chloric and what happened with
hydroxychloroquine was
a we had a radioactive president
prematurely
say this is
absolutely magic
a tremendous amount of internal
hostility
toward the president inside the
administration massive shocking
that was going to
do anything it could to block that this
is my opinion
um
and then uh
there was
a lot of premature data that came out
that was not that was simply like
anecdotal and uh poor studies were then
done that were looking at it in late
stage or later stage disease when no one
most people did not think that's when
the drug would be effective and so it
got up it got sort of a steamrolled
negative thing
if you read there's a couple papers by
uh joe ladapo and others he's a ucla
physician who did a compilation of the
research on hydroxychloroquine
and it's it's it's pretty good data
and there's a lot of studies out that
show that it's pre it seems i'm not an
expert on that data by the way i haven't
really spent a lot of time looking at it
seems that it's effective in early
disease and possibly but we don't know
uh it's at least being studied for
prophylaxis like you take and i have
taken hydroxychloroquine for malaria
prophylaxis many years ago
uh
but it's thought if it's effective it's
effective in early stage disease
ivermectin i don't know much about but
it's sort of there's pretty
very uh positive data about it that
again a lot of these studies are
criticized because they're not these
perfect randomized controlled studies
but as we all know haven't seen a lot of
randomized controlled studies about
masks and six foot social distancing
by the way just sort of an interesting
aside it has nothing to do with their
question but you know the who says three
feet
and many countries use three feet now
why is that important it's important to
know because a it shows how arbitrary
the rule is
it's not that three feet is the is the
right number i'm not saying that but it
also shows if it's three feet that's a
that's a that's a game changer for a
restaurant for instance
you know because three feet away i mean
unless you're with the person you're not
sitting three feet uh you know usually i
mean there are certain wrestlers so you
know these kinds of things are just
pointing out how arbitrary these rules
have been
it's clear social distancing will
eliminate and it will will stop the
spread of an infection and my analogy is
if i'm in paris and you're in london
you're breathing the same air generally
but you're not going to get it you're
far enough away now i don't know about
six feet no one knows it's never been
proven
uh and there's a lot of horror stories
about how the six foot rule came about
in that situation room but it happened
before i was there so i won't claim to
know that but it's it's a joke
the drug studies uh
have been uh perverted the whole climate
has been uh destroyed by the politics
and it's very sad because frankly in my
opinion people were killed
because of the politics of of uh
stopping the drug data from coming out
[Applause]
please join please join me in thanking
dr alice
you